what up chooms thank you once again for
clicking on another video of mine and
you know the drill as we start out want
to give some love this video sponsor no
stranger to this channel because once
again the doctor is in that would be dr
squatch it is true that i use their soap
and i love their soap dr squatch truly
is changing the way men approach hygiene
by providing high performing natural
products that make you feel great smell
great they don't use those harmful
chemicals that some other soap companies
use in their soap but they don't just
have soap soap deodorant shampoo
conditioner a regular full shower
routine here also beard oil because what
is the claim of clean if your beard
doesn't smell like a tree i'll tell ya
false it does smell nice
i like pine smells it's a thing and if
you're not completely satisfied dr
squatch has a no questions asked money
back guarantee you know i love me the
peace of mind that comes with a money
back guarantee so click the link below
and use my promo code dsq john's and new
customers can get 20 off of an order of
20 or more and thank you once again to
dr squatch for sponsoring this video i
do appreciate it all right now that
we've talked about getting clean let's
talk about that
i could have said that dirtier but you
know
let's
so x is a new film directed by ty west
also an a24 film which usually it's
saying the studio whenever an ad or a
trailer is like from the studio that
brought you i'm like it's
kind of ridiculous usually i can just be
like you're being universal
what does that mean two studios are
worth noting and that's marvel studios
and a24 which is funny because they're
kind of the antithesis of each other but
you list either of those you kind of
know what you're in for generally
speaking fingers crossed you're in for
some surprises and with x definitely was
the premise of x is 1979 a group of
people get together and they rent out a
place on this old couple's farm in the
name of making a porno not just any poor
no they want to make a classy artsy porn
they want to elevate the porn genre and
then it turns into a slasher flick
they'll start dying in crazy bloody
fashion but hearing the premise just
saying it out loud this movie could have
slipped into satire so easily and
although you see homage in this film it
never comes across as satire actually
found it to be a really unique movie
going horror experience also 824 you
know it's slow burn i feel like a 24 is
one of those studios like it has that in
its contract someone comes to them with
an idea they're like all right great
great idea uh are you gonna make it a
slow burn yes great here's your budget i
just i say that for the people that
might be like tits and gord i just
signed me up i mean that's kind of how i
was now the cast does a great job in
this movie funny enough who is this noah
why
because you got that x factor
yeah that's not matthew mcconaughey i
just briefly saw the trailer i was like
okay i've seen enough of the trailer and
go see this movie today mcconaughey's in
a movie crazy i stopped the trailer
before i got a good look at oh
it's not mcconaughey that's actor martin
henderson because of that experience
there's a part of me that wants to be
like i guess he's the guy he cast when
he can't get mcconaughey but that's just
a disservice because i thought he was
great in the movie i thought everyone
was great in this movie everybody nailed
it that was not meant to be a pun you
get your head out of the dirty gutter
while i talk about the movie about porn
people getting slashed up it mainly
revolves around mia goth also jenna
ortega seeing her kind of rise up in the
horror movie rank she was in the new
scream also the kills i guess i've
talked it up a little bit i mean they're
gory it's bloody but in realistic
fashion that's what makes it horrific
i've seen gory or bloody things on
screen but there's a lot of disturbing
imagery in here i guess that's that's
where the movie excels it's not that
it's bloody it's that there's disturbing
[ __ ] not just revolving around blood and
a lot of it has to do with the message
in the movie that the movie's sending
out the audience is taken in that has to
do with
the contrast of age age and regret and
doing things when you're young that you
can't do when you're older
there's a whole layered thing going on
here that really surprised me i just
didn't expect it porn and blood also
hear some profound [ __ ] but i didn't
expect it now beyond gore and horrific
imagery is the movie graphic sex wise
they are making porn after all uh yeah i
mean i thought it was riding the line of
what rated r can do and can show like
it's still rated r but in the video
rental store like teenage jeremy look at
the top shelf like oh x i heard about
this hold the vhs like i can feel the
skin
through the plastic this is actually man
hunter
i have a whole collection i found out
that there's a vhs community called
tapeheads didn't know i was part of
anything like that but
one can say i am but right it kind of
feels like it'd be one of those movies
then i'd watch it and be like oh heavy
movie but one of the more impressive
things about this movie is how it weaves
the theme and imagery
of making porn
into some of the horror elements hard to
explain but it's in here but in wrapping
this up in the end x i really enjoyed it
i dug it it's the product of what a
creative mind can do
with what sounds like a ridiculous
satirical premise on paper for instance
it has dark comedy in it there's those
moments where you're like oh that's
really clever kind of am i the only one
who finds that funny it might be maybe
maybe it's not funny maybe it's just
like at this point my soul is so
blackened but there are things i found
funny the excellent tension great
performances by the cast great violence
and gore payoff in the last act though
it's more because it's realistic is what
makes it horrifying and legitimately
dealing with deep themes makes this a
movie that it's what i'm gonna remember
i thought it was a disturbingly good
time no alcohol required but again not
for everybody like if you if on the
weekends you go out there like
hello have you heard the latest about
our lord and savior jesus christ this
might not be for you you just gotta know
that all right so x have you seen it
what did you think about it did it
surprise you did it horrify you did you
like it are you never gonna watch it
again did you even know this movie came
out whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you